let's get some practice estimating
lengths so they tell us this line is one
inch so that distance right over there
is one inch about how long is a toy car
well this is one of those lines that it
just did so that's one inch but let's
just see how many of those we need to go
the whole length of the car so if I were
to draw another one if I were to draw
another one it's about that and I'm
estimating it's not exact that would be
two inches it's one inch that's two
inches then that would be three inches
and then that would be four inches four
inches so it looks like the car is about
four inches four inches let's do another
one of these estimating length problems
so I have a picture of two sunflowers
right over here and they tell us that
this first sunflower is 40 centimeters
tall about how long is the second
sunflower going to be well let's think
about it if this entire distance if this
entire height is 40 centimeters is about
40 centimeters and this sunflower if you
look at its height if we look at its
height I'll draw a dotted line here it
looks like it's about half of the height
of the taller centum of the taller
sunflower so what is half of 40 going to
be well 40 is for tens half of four tens
is going to be two tens so this looks
like it's about 20 centimeters 20 let me
write it this way this looks like it's
about 20 centimeters another way to
think about it if this whole thing is 40
centimeters so then and this is what
half would be 20 then this would be 10
centimeters let me write this this would
be 10 centimeters this would be 20
centimeters then this would be 30
centimeters and then this would be 40
centimeters so we already saw that the
sunflower is 40 centimeters tall and
then this one would be half of that it
would be 20 centimeters tall